[Música]
vou falar um pouquinho da minha
trajetória é vou mostrar algumas imagens
de quando era criança
essa foto
ela foi muito usada pela minha irmã para
me chantagear porque ela sabe que eu não
gostava então eu sempre usava quando eu
não queria fazer alguma coisa pra ela
falando mostrar fotos pra todo mundo
agora não tem como missão já que o mundo
inteiro vai ver
então é essa outra foto é um concurso
que eu participei na escola e há muita
gente fala que a gente bonitinho né que
a gente vai ganhar então a gente vai
toda empolgada acreditando que vai
ganhar mas eu perdi eu perdi e fiquei
muito triste por isso é é um me senti
uma derrotada como criança sempre
dramática né
eu tava morrendo na verdade então assim
essas duas escolas que representa
bastante infância e eu cresci muito
rápido amadurecimento rápido é com 12
anos eu já me achava adulta achava que
eu tinha que trabalhar e eu tinha minhas
coisas né
e eu comecei a ir pra feira vender
pastéis prometia e ela sempre me davam
trocada e esse trocado eu colocava no
cofre
aí aos 14 anos eu também com essa
vontade de trabalhar
já achava que estava muito velha deixava
minha mãe doido né não quero trabalhar
aí eu comecei a fazer um curso
profissionalizante e nesse curso era
sobre secretariado computação lepra que
na época também era uma realidade isso e
comecei a fazer esse curso é o marketing
desse curso é que a gente saia dele é
empregado não saía com o trabalho era um
curso de dois anos
e aos 16 anos no último dia do curso
realmente eles é arrumar uma entrevista
de emprego pra mim eu fui conseguir a
vaga em um escritório de engenharia onde
eu fiquei por quatro anos e meio é em
toda essa trajetória eu tinha um sonho
queria ter meu carro
aos 18 anos vou tirar minha habilitação
e vou comprar um carro
isso é que eu tinha em mente e os 18
anos
eu comprei um carro juntei mil reais
fui lá andar pela cidade encontrei o
carro liguei para o meu pai eu falei
assim estou comprando carro porque da
minha família a gente nunca teve carro
celta comprando carro ele quer comprar
um carro me passar seus dados que eu vou
colocar no seu nome a ele passou
coloquei comprei o carro e eu pensei
nossa 36 meses sem e para a faculdade
porque 80% do meu salário estava na
prestação do carro aí um belo dia eu
tinha acabado no terceiro ano e 9 em
casa tranquilo dentro tinha aula à noite
meu pai queijo que você não vai estudar
mais
não sou assim mas 80% ela estava no
carro como eu ia pagar a glória escolhe
o curso que você quer e depois o perfil
do eleitor vai escolher mas eu tenho um
compromisso com você paga 50% da
mensalidade e foi escolhe o curso
encontra a arquitetura não queria parar
de trabalhar e até procurar um curso
noturno
[Música]
então encontrei
aí eu passei eu prestei o vestibular e
não passei então pra mim foi a derrota
me sentindo capaz e um amigo meu falou
olha vai ter o vai ter um vestibular
para bolsas neto bolsistas e tatá
impressões vestibular
eu passei cheguei pro meu pai falei
paguei os 50% que eu tinha prometido né
porque como sabe como paguei meus 50 por
cento com essa bolsa então aqui foi o
dia da população de grau
todas as fotos e tocar deixado porque
foi um emoção gigantesca pra mim e
comecei nessa trajetória da arquitetura
e hoje eu estou como diretora do
departamento de atividades culturais do
instituto de engenharia e arquitetura do
triângulo mineiro
essa é uma foto do dia da posse então é
uma foto que que me representa muito né
e alguns alguns projetos então vem
realizando alguns eventos
essa falta de uma amiga minha também que
me ajuda muito
então esse é uma foto do evento feminino
que eu fiz junto com meu grupo raízes do
brasil e algumas fotos de projetos nem
que eu fui para representá essa
trajetória que eu venho trabalhando com
arquitetura
então essa é a primeira mulher que eu me
tornei agora a segunda mulher que eu me
tornei foi há um ano atrás que encontrei
outra jitsu é encontrei o mundo dos
campeonatos foi muito feliz no meu
primeiro campeonato porque eu fiquei em
primeiro lugar e me apaixonei isso me dá
um incentivo pra tá me inscrevendo os
próximos e no segundo campeonato
eu perdi aí me remeteu aquela pontinha
quando eu estava no desfile né que eu
fiquei muito envergonhada
então eu não consegui olhar para as
pessoas eu só chorava
é eu a minha equipe nem estava toda lá
no dia da luta assim eu chorava muito e
não conseguia interage com eles tanto
vergonha que eu tenho treinado muito e
perdi né então a partir daí a gente
sempre tem os campeonatos e e o meu
senso ele perguntou se eu ia pro próximo
e eu estava muito insegura porque eu
tinha perdido 13 tanto e perdi
e quem é refletindo sobre o que eu
queria
a mensagem que eu teria que tirar desse
desse campeonato que eu não ganhei então
eu pensei eu não vou desistir porque eu
passou pela minha cabeça desistir por
conta do medo
então eu acredito muito que a primeira
vez que a gente tem medo a gente recua a
gente sempre vai entender recuar
então no último dia da inscrição eu me
inscrevi e ganhei e fiquei em primeiro
lugar novamente
então pra mim foi outra felicidade né
lógico que eu continuo é conseguir um
patrocinador então continuo nessa essa
campanha é nessa caminhada aqui a foto
de outro campeonato que eu também perdi
era uma luta casada mas com o pensamento
diferente porque eu acho que na vida e
no em campeonatos argentino melhor a
gente pode estar melhor naquele momento
naquele minuto e naquele momento eu não
estava melhor lê é é a minha oponente
ela estava melhor
então mas não pára por aí e vários
outros estão por vir
essa foto representa a terceira mulher
que eu estou no porto é a um ano atrás
também
eu mesmo com a caminhada da arquitetura
eu vendia vendo neco de jóias
o contrato ou e um dia um rapaz que é
dono dessas jóias ele a loja dele teria
que ficar fechado por meio período e eu
me ofereci para ficar nesse meio período
na loja dele e um belo dia chegou duas
senhoras é e querendo fazer uma solda
que ela não é fazer uma solda numa
corrente e eu não sabia fazer e ela
queria para aquele momento então eu
falei que não teria como aí quando ele
chegou eu falei olha a gente perdeu duas
sondas hoje ensina a fazer lhe falte
ensina a fazer dessa solda eu desenhei o
anel queria fazer se é ou não me estou a
fazer me ensinou a fazer o anel ele isso
um amigo meu também pediu para desenhar
um anel e foi essa caminhada e comecei a
desenvolver as jóias e deixar ele de
ficar pelado né porque toda vez eu
desenhava gemol queria queria que ele me
ensinar como o que fazia
aí eu liguei essa criatividade é tanto
de desenho né
e como de criação pela minha profissão
de arquiteta eu liguei isso com a
prática de ourives e eu brinquei também
essa prática de outros com o jiu jitsu
que eu comecei a fazer umas peças uns
pingentes escrito jitsu é algumas peças
escrito os que é o nosso comprimento no
tatame e comecei a postar toda a
produção como era feito o pessoal
começou a gostar começou a pedir
encomendas e eu vi nessa caminhada né
então essa é a terceira pessoa que eu me
tornei algumas longos de empresas também
comecei a fazer e algumas peças
personalizadas
então assim é quando eu fui convidada
pra fazer pra falar sobre essa
transformação às vezes a gente fica
muito pensativa né
hoje por não ser uma pessoa que
descobriu um aplicativo que de sucesso
ou então quando a gente não revolucionou
engenharia
entre outras coisas e fiquei pensando
que eu poderia a mensagem que eu poderia
passar de transformação para todo mundo
que está aqui então nada melhor como
contar uma história de uma pessoa comum
a nec tinha sempre teve vários desejos e
estou nessa caminhada me transformando
todos os dias e então a mensagem que eu
deixo todos os dias eu acordo eu sempre
agradeço e falo que hoje é o dia mais
feliz da minha vida e eu sempre coloco
um propósito de fazer pelo menos uma
pessoa sorri de alguma forma então a
mensagem é que eu me transformei em
todas as mulheres que eu desejei ser um
dia porque hoje eu sou uma arquiteta
eu sou um empreendedor de jóias e eu sou
uma atleta campeão
[Música]